I get criticized all the time for
work-life balance people are like well
you don't have any hobbies Alex I don't
want any so why do I have to
sacrifice things that I would prefer to
do to do things I don't want to do to
satisfy your objective measure of what
you deem as work-life balance why this
is what you were talking about uh was it
optimized for the outcome or what's the
metric of success yeah he was saying
like what is it that people are
optimizing for right it seems to me that
you have stepped back and decided this
is the thing that I'm optimizing for
that I enjoy most doing yes that's I
enjoy playing the game and so everything
I do is about the game yes my podcast is
called the game I draw pictures all day
about business I write books about
business I make content about business
I've never seen a picture offers zillion
pictures in there oh they've done by you
100 all of the drawings are mine and I
spend the rest of my day doing business
why don't you Garden because I don't
care